we've seen a bunch of these articles a
bunch of these tweets
they're threatening to riot over amy
coney barrett they're threatening to
riot
just again because of louisville because
of brad taylor
now now uh jack posobik tweeted that
there's you know kenosha is preparing an
announcement
we'll see what happens some people think
it's about kyle retinas i doubt it's
probably about the officers not getting
charged or something
personally based on that news alone i
kind of feel like
it's gonna it's gonna kick off i mean
they're threatening it for a variety of
reasons
so i guess my question is do you agree
and
do you guys see this getting worse over
the next couple of months like are we
going to see
are we going to see more cow right now
situations i mean
i don't want to say like it's going to
get worse but to be honest i i mean i
think it is from what i've been seeing
just because
the country's so divided and then like i
feel like the election is just gonna
like send this thing overboard
um one big thing for me that i kind of
keep telling people is
you know whether if if biden wins um the
right's not gonna accept it if trump
wins the left's not get accepted and
we're just in a crazy time
you know the women's march like i said
moved up their event to october 17. you
know usually they wait till after the
election
and you know i don't know what's what's
gonna happen but
it definitely seems that uh it's not
getting any any better i mean from what
from what i've seen on the ground
it's definitely it's definitely not
getting any any better what do you think
shall we i don't know
i i would agree i think your question
about if there's going to be
more written house situations you know
you you hope not
of course um i i think that
there's there's a definite you know
something to be said
17 year olds with whatever i'm not a gun
person
what did he have a 2 2 3 the big was it
an ar-15
yeah the ar-15 going into these
very volatile situations where
things can change at the blink of an eye
like they you're not trained for that
you know what i mean and
and if you want to go and whatever
reason he had for being there um
will we see it again again you hope not
but can i say
no of course not i can't see i can't
predict the future but i do think that
um
there there will be riots i think
there's been ups and downs all this year
uh and and we'll see and up again
and i think we're starting to see kind
of a a portion of america
that is getting really sick and tired of
seeing their cities destroyed and it's
getting to a point where they're saying
if i have to pick up a gun
and i have to go out there and do it
myself then i will and that's what that
kyle ren house situation was
that's dangerous yeah i think it's it's
you know it's not a
good president for our country to be in
we'll you know we'll see what happens
but
i mean when we have the destruction that
we're seeing you're going to have a
portion of people
who feel that they are not protected and
they have to do something for the
community and we're going to continue to
see that until
you know we see some type of you know
law order restored you know
f hopefully coming into this new year
with this election but like i said i
i don't think so what do you think
richie yeah
well what i think is that what i've
noticed is an
ongoing theme from across all these
protests and we were talking about this
yesterday
is that the individuals who are out
there everybody has a cause right
and the ones who are actually engaging
in the violence
are perhaps the most lost in terms of
how
much they're putting into it and how
much they hate for example law
enforcement
so what we saw in kenosha was
basically two different sides that had
causes that they really believed in
and in a situation where there's no law
enforcement
well they were close but clearly they
weren't you know doing their normal jobs
they were doing riot control
they weren't you know trying to keep
obviously
kyle rittenhouse from what were they
doing they weren't protecting the
businesses
the windows were getting smashed the
fires were starting well i think that
actually comparing dc's riot control to
kenosha i mean dc is literally they're
babysitting
that crowd the entire time that they're
out marching there's a little bit of
irony there
that you know the cops are stopping the
traffic for the protesters who want to
stop the traffic
to keep them safe but in kenosha that
was not the case and
that's that's what i'm saying is it the
first or the second night because the
first night
we weren't there that's when things
really popped off the second night was
when
everything burned to the ground the
third night was the shooting uh and the
second night i think
kenosha was just so unprepared
and and it caused these individuals
these armed individuals to come out
in the third night they were there the
second night protecting one
gas station but there was only what
three or four of them and then the
second
or the third night when the shooting
happened there were
you know double or triple i would say
that amount um and the more small cities
where that kind of stuff
happens the law enforcement isn't
trained for that
and so that's the reason why i'm using
dc as an example and if that just
continues to spread across our country
i do think you guys know that ammo
shortages across the country you can't
get nine millimeter
i mean i went to i've been now to i
think two different shops
and they got nothing they got no ammo
because everybody and i was at a shop
recently a guy walks in and he walks up
and he's like you got nine millimeter
and the guys
no and apparently it's like a dollar
around now up from like a dime or
something it's like
it's just it's sold out what's what
what's interesting about it is that for
one liberals have started buying up guns
these people who normally passively just
said yeah gun control i was under
gun owners record gun sales ammo gets
bought up like crazy
so what what does that mean for small
towns towns like kenosha
where law enforcement isn't getting the
job done where we we see these district
attorneys not prosecuting
i that's what i'm worried about man i'm
worried i think kyle should not have
been out there
but i think the police should have been
out there i think the writers shouldn't
have like
there's there's multiple steps we have
to clear before we get to blaming kyle
for being uh you know i think a dumb kid
it's riots shouldn't happen it was a
failure on on multiple ends
absolutely and then finally you get this
kid now they're smearing him and calling
all these crazy things
i don't think he was being smart it
sounds basically what you guys are
saying sounds like he's really dumb
waving the gun you know running like not
knowing what he was doing
and apparently it wasn't even his gun it
was given to him by somebody else
so what i see there is i'm more
concerned about the bigger picture than
i am
him as an individual the bigger picture
is that
you're going to get more inexperienced
people they're going to be handed guns
what happens when there's a small town
in i don't know
pennsylvania you know maybe maybe it's a
town of like 30 000 people so it's not
you know the biggest town but that's 30
000 people and what happens when the
writers show up
and then some dude hands a handgun like
laws be damned
we're not we're not gonna burn take this
weapon and that person's never fired
before
it's it's you know we can talk about the
laws and gun control all day and night
but when it comes to someone marching
down your street with a torch or a brick
or a molotov
people are gonna be like i don't care
you know when people talk about whether
kyle should have had the weapon or not
i mean that's look the kid picked up the
weapon when he's
like not legally allowed to have it
because he was he was 17 not 18.
what do you think people are going to do
it's it's like it's it's
you come to that neighborhood they're
gonna say i can't i don't have the
luxury of worrying about what comes
after with these these these laws i have
to worry about right now the guy in
front of my house the molotov
that's what i'm worried about happening
and we kind of saw that example
too when we were um in louisville
kentucky um there was that moment that
that that i was able to capture with the
the middle eastern business owner
uh where you just have this huge model
oh that was uh
what's his name fari yeah yeah and um
i went i visited him earlier in the in
the day before i even got that video so
so real quick this is a guy who was like
surrounded and was refusing to say black
lives matter yeah
yeah and the thing was is um so he has a
smoke shop
then like right there he's leasing
another business that was firebomb
the night before so i i showed up when
they were still doing investigation
and you know he was very very upset they
don't want to they don't want to speak
to me and i don't i don't blame him you
know he just had a business firebomb
and then later that night um you know me
and so we're kind of following this
crowd
and then that's when we see i just see
this huge you know kind of
like a mob start to approach him and
then they they come up to him and say
you know does brianna taylor's life
matter does does you know black lives
matter trying to get him to say and he
you know he wouldn't say that
you know he was chilling there with his
gun but even that situation
could have ended you know bad i mean he
was he you know he was cool coming
collective
um but just we're just seeing those type
of examples
all across the country where people
don't even trust the cops anymore to
restore law in order
they have to literally sit in front of
their business throughout the whole
night if they have to just to make sure
it doesn't you know
and all it takes is one person with a
gun
who doesn't quite know what they're
doing or
gets frazzled or gets surrounded
and that's literally those people were
kind of charging them they were kind of
getting they were
getting these guys they were yelling at
him so i mean like i said you know thank
god he was cool calm and collective
but like you know like we said if it was
another individual was inexperienced as
soon as people charged up they could
already
they already like you know yeah you know
gun swinging so it was just a
you know crazy moment to capture and
then you know when we post it it's just
it's opening americans eyes to like what
what's happening on the ground
it's crazy to me that uh in the debates
joe biden says antifa doesn't exist and
it's not just antifa it's just
i think the bigger issue is far left
extremism it's crazy to me that you get
like from the fbi oh oh
you know right wing and white supremacy
are the biggest threats and i'm like
they talk about the proud boys and you
know i was saying this earlier
if 300 proud boys like started marching
around my neighborhood you know what i
would do
literally nothing i wouldn't care like
when the proud boys have come out
and they're they're left to their own
devices they just wave little american
flags and then get drunk
and then they leave and they yell uhuru
or whatever it is they do
if i heard that black lives matter
antifa was coming i'd pack up and
get out i i'm not going to stick around
because we've already seen what happens
when they come to your property and
threaten you the cops arrest you
you know we see what happens to people
who who panic not saying it's a good
thing but you know think they got to
defend their neighborhood they're going
to arrest you
i'm not worried about proud boys nobody
knows who they are they're not even
there's not even that many of them
but these the far left unrest has been
everywhere
i i got i got a call from a friend in
the far west uh chicago suburbs
dinky tiny little town yep they showed
up and they didn't even live there
that's scary so then you see in the in
the debates
joe biden won't denounce it joe biden's
campaign staff bailing these people out
minneapolis kamala hair soliciting
donations to bail these people out
i am worried that you know right now
there's the debate over who's america is
this trump says in biden's america this
is what you'll get and people laugh and
say yeah trump you're president now
and i'm like nah here's the way i see it
they deputized
the uh oregon state police in port in in
oregon
they then deputized the portland police
so now if you get arrested by the state
troopers or the portland pd
the feds charge you and that's freaking
these people out
that's trump joe biden his campaign
staff
bailing these people out i'm worried
that if biden gets elected it's gonna
hit it's gonna be
let's negotiate and figure out what we
can do to to to appease them
yeah they might start they might stop
rioting because biden the democrats are
gonna be like here are the things you've
asked for
like we're gonna give in to your demands
i think if trump gets elected he's going
to be like he's going to put on the iron
gauntlet slam his iron fist
but i don't know man i don't know if you
guys get that political on the issue
because i think you're mostly just on
the ground reporters and i'm talking
about politics but
i don't know if you have any thoughts on
you know like well yeah what do you
think about the local government what do
you think about
trump's responses do you think they've
said trump's made it worse
do you guys have any opinions i mean
from i mean one one thing that i could
kind of take away is
when we were like covering the the
situation in like seattle and chaz uh
when we go you know i'll just you know
go out to just speak to regular folks in
seattle
even like um one thing i found
interesting was like the trump
supporters and the conservatives
they got to a point where they really
wanted trump to intervene and not kind
of use it as like uh like a political
playground you know because trump will
come out and say hey well that's
happening in democrat cities let them
burn
but people forget there's trump
supporters in those democrat cities who
do want
you know to see their city or state you
know see the law in order to restore so
that's one thing that i took away was
folks in seattle and then conservatives
in portland
they got to the point where they
actually want to see trump like actually
come in
and do something and not kind of see see
them kind of bashing their their city so
i found that interesting but you know
every every city is different
every situation is different i think i
think with the the situation in
louisville
the i think they wanted to avoid the
chaos so bad
that they just said hey we're going to
declare unlawful assemblies like right
when curfew occurs and we're just
arresting everyone
and hopefully that sends a message i
mean one thing that i could kind of take
away from my jail experience was
uh what with the men that i was with is
after they were in jail they
all almost all of them said we're not
coming back anymore
like this is it like after after being
here this sucks
and like the people that i met at least
in my cell were mostly out of towner so
i had people from indiana detroit and
ohio
that were that were down in louisville
and almost like nine
nine ten of them said dude we're not
coming back after this like this sucks
so i don't know
if that's maybe that needs to happen in
more cities where you just
mass arrest these people and just maybe
send a message um
we'll see if that works because i know
in portland people were getting arrested
and getting turned around in like three
four hours already out
coming right back yeah so maybe that's
that's what needs to happen
um when we were like when i went to
atlanta after rashar brooks
it was the the unrest was bad because we
were at the wendy's where where he got
killed and there was literally it was a
no-cop go zone so
the the like the gangsters in that hood
ran
that wendy's and they literally did not
let white people in and out so that was
in atlanta in atlanta so that that was
one of the good times that shelby and
richie weren't with me because
they probably wouldn't have been even
let in into the no-go zone
so and that wasn't reported yeah and the
thing
one thing that bothered me when we were
in atlanta was that me and another
reporter julia rosa we were blasting on
social media trying to show people
the violence happening in that little
section because it was a no-go zone
the three nights that we were on the
ground reporting two of the nights shots
were fired at the wendy's so we were
that we were there for that
and no almost it didn't get any traction
with any any big media or law
enforcement even the very next week
after we were gone is when that
eight-year-old girl
went to visit that that vigil and got
shot and killed and it took
it took that moment for them to say okay
we're sitting national guard
same thing at chaz we went in there and
like attacked it
attacked it you know trying to expose it
and then it took two people getting shot
and killed for
for you know for something to happen but
it's just been a
you know every city is different i don't
know how you know what's the correct way
to handle it but um it's kind of been
interesting just to kind of
get that feedback one of the first
things i asked you guys i was like oh
you've clearly got time to be here
you know we've had like you know for the
past four months every day i wake up i'm
like oh it's my
like i do a segment in the morning my my
morning riot update for everybody turn
on your car stairs on your way to work
and listen about the riots
because every night every single night
there have been a couple
over the past few nights and this this
actually freaks me out
i didn't talk about them because the
politics stuff is getting bigger and
i've mentioned before that's actually a
problem because
it's normalized like the stuff happening
in the pacific northwest
now it's just like oh they're throwing
firebombs again you know
what am i really going to tell anybody
hey they threw firebombs again all right
have a nice day
i was talking to richie about that
earlier actually we were
sort of looking at where the unrest is
right now and i
said something like you know it's
portland and seattle like they're not
pro they're not doing this for like any
reason
it's just violence at this point you
know they're
it's not like louisville where they
began protesting over the brianna taylor
uh the verdict it's they're just doing
it
to cause chaos
and so it's it's less interesting almost
it's yeah because it
you know compared to going to louisville
or potentially going to kenosha
next week depending on what happens wait
is there news coming out
well we don't know what the news is but
something's about that something
allegedly is about to happen um so
that's interesting because it's
something sparked it and in like
portland it's just i don't know what's
sparking it like they
they got what they wanted right like the
national guard stood down and then
people and there's
still violence and chaos going on and
yeah it didn't work well i i agree with
that
and i think what kenosha and my
experience my personal experience with
kenosha really
the lesson that i learned there is
the degree to which the facts on the
ground are being neglected
in favor of whatever narrative you want
to push
and i think both sides are guilty of
that but specifically
uh you know with respect to kyle um
it was weeks before you know cnn
uh washington post contacted me uh and i
think
part of the reason is because my
testimony they just
it didn't fit what they wanted to put
out there
wait so they didn't they didn't like hit
you up like hey you're like the
witness you were involved they didn't
talk to you or what i think what
what happened was basically then
uh wednesday night after the shooting i
went on tucker carlson
and my goal in this is one thing and one
thing only and that's
to tell the public the greater public
not just one echo chamber what i saw
and i think after i went on tucker that
really turned off
half of the media establishment from
what i had to say
and there's actually a cnn report that
said that i supported the conservative
belief that written house
acted in self-defense it said that but
you never said that
i said kyle told me that he was there
to protect the small businesses right
and he mentioned an absence of police
so i wasn't supporting any claim i'm i'm
playing a role here as a witness so
having experienced that i really learned
the degree to which you know
the facts on the ground can just don't
even matter anymore so i think that's
what's different now
than you know previous riots i i i take
a look at like uh
the press conference held by these
doctors over kovid breitbart did a live
stream of it
and then facebook deleted it because it
was misinformation but i'm like but it's
just a press conference that was hosted
by doctors and a republican politician
yeah why is the news organization being
struck down
your story is similar in the sense that
if the narrative doesn't fit
the news organization is you're a
provocateur you're not a journalist
anymore the moment you say something
steps out of line like
andy no all these news organizations say
right wing provocateur and it's like
what what has he done other than just
like here's people here's what they're
doing
here's a video of it nope that makes him
an activist a provocateur
and i think part of it too has to do
with how prominent
you know andy started getting so uh
frozen from hillary and you know is just
he's a journalist in the pacific
northwest who covers far-left violence
he calls it what it is
and now that he's gained more and more
followers as he's you know publishing a
lot of this information and exposing
what these people are doing
they now he's so you know well known
they say he's a right-wing provocateur
i'm not i'm i don't i don't know of any
right-wing groups that he's a he's a
part of like
he's not partisan he's not talking about
voting for trump he i think he said that
he's like center right
politically or something with that
effect but that erases his identity as a
journalist
and that's it it's it's i i don't know
uh if you guys can even comment on this
like why it is that you think the media
is downplaying or even protecting the
extremists that are causing the violence
i mean i think i mean i just off the bed
i would say maybe it has to
do something with it you know doesn't
protect their side doesn't fit
the narrative for for for their side
it's it's it's hard to tell
um but like like how we said we you know
we try to be out there
try to get the full scoop show you guys
everything and then let let you decide
it's it's it's difficult to understand i
mean one thing that bothered me was that
thing in kenosha where
you know i didn't even see any like
reporters talking to the business owners
you know these people
are are devastated you know livelihood
gone you know who's gonna share their
stories you know that we ran into one
witness who said
a seven-year-old man was beat trying to
protect his business
still burning i saw that video yeah and
they smashed him over the back of the
head and to me it was just like you know
if you're in media news why are we not
sharing
these stories of these these are
americans just like us they're they're
in the middle class
you know they're they work nine to five
jobs you know we should be sharing these
stories and i don't know
you know i'm i'm only i'm only been in
dc for four months but i don't know if
it's like the
the whole connection of you know you
always hear the rumors before you move
to dc hey
don't get uh like too caught up in your
dc bubble like you know
don't forget like to to us real
americans and maybe that is a thing
where
where they're so caught up in this dc
bubble they're like well hey
i could look out the window and my high
rise isn't burning down so the whole
everyone's doing fine oh dude
um so i don't know if it's that aspect
but to me i think that
i mean that's for me just that folks
folks are too elite in media do you
remember that tweet from the guy in like
hollywood where he's like yeah they're
riding woo and then
oh no the rights are near my house stop
stop go the other way go to the poor
neighborhood bro
i actually yeah i've been in dc for 12
years so i can definitely comment
uh and i worked at nbc one of my first
weeks there
was the new town shooting and i wow that
will forever stick out in my head
because when you have people who sit in
these multi-million dollar studios
and they talk about these human
tragedies day in and day out i think
there's a certain
callousness that you develop and having
experienced that human suffering
firsthand literally having rosenbaum
dying in my arms
i am now so much more aware of of the
actual suffering that is taking place
as a byproduct of what's happening in
our country right now and that's not
just
in the riots that's why are these people
mad in the first place
why are they going out there and so
desperate to
you know tear down the fence around the
federal courthouse in portland and the
answer is
it all starts with the economics and and
our generation you know i'm 31 and i
won't
say how old shelby is she's very young
but our generation
no shame we've talked about this
extensively
they're we're one of the first probably
the first generation of americans who
are inheriting
in america that's less prosperous than
what our parents
grew up in or entered their professional
lives in i think there's a profound
disillusionment
that's happening in in 20-somethings and
you know
millennials and i think that's the real
root
and nobody wants to talk about that
nobody wants to talk about the mental
health or opioids because it's
if it bleeds it leads you know what i
mean i think it's a lack of purpose like
no one's got anything to do no one knows
why they're here
we've uh talked about that a little bit
too like
these groups it almost seems like they
don't know
who they are what they want and this is
a
like this is a community for people as
strange as it sounds it's you know a
team it's something
to fight for and belong to and
and i think and i think that the media i
think also
it's so um
divisive these days like with trump you
know if trump says something
i think and this does not mean i am
pro-trump
or anything you know i'm very
non-political
but but you can just see it you know you
don't have to be political to see that
if trump says something
many people in the media just
automatically go to the other end of the
spectrum
in the most extreme way so what has
trump done he has called out these
violent riots he has you know used them
he has
spoken about them and so the media
downplays them and i think that
is definitely a part of it as well so
trump needs to come out and support
antifa for them to finally crack down
their rights
great they're the best i love what they
do trump is supporting violent
extremists these people
and then they go full capitalist trump
just announces a communist and then
they're like perfect
i mean that that is an ongoing joke from
like the babylon bee it's like other
sites whatever trump says i say the
opposite yeah
but one thing i actually kind of wanted
to mention kind of piggyback what they
were saying too is you know being on the
ground
and like just striking some
conversations with folks um
i think it's that too is the the la the
the lack of purpose in their life
i think a lot of folks that i've met
they kind of see this as like a moment
of revolution
so it kind of fills that void i mean one
thing that i would be more interested in
if i could ever have a chance to sit
down is just you know finding more about
these people's family lives
you know i think that one thing that we
don't talk about in media and politics
is just like
you know the you know having a strong
family structure
is a big big deal in our society and i i
think we shouldn't shy away from that
conversation
we should we should be speaking about it
especially in 2020 in a time like this
we should we should be talking about
family again that's just me yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you